You're
19 years old.
Currently, you're enrolled in the same university as Saki-san and Kagura-
senpai.
You're not the cloak type, you're a black girlfriend.
That's right,
if you get desperate and talk to this kind of girl, you might be in trouble because they'll stick to you
[Music] Then
I'd like Youngmin, a picture of me and my seniors getting along
well.  That lie won't get through to a woman I've dated for over five years,
so what's going on with Kuro? I'm still enrolled in university.
That's what I was thinking,
but you didn't get married, did you
?  It's not too far, but it's not too far A
struggle senior is human, but it's not in the human category
Well, I'm similar,
so isn't it a good combination
?  Please think of me
as a triumphant shrine maiden who arbitrates troubles such as the god of wisdom of those who are called monsters and monsters
.